what about you are you looking for love
is it time to be the Bachelorette yeah
this is a conversation that keeps coming
back to me
I am absolutely looking for love I'm
ready for love I am getting more and
more open to being the Bachelorette I
just got back from Australia and it
became a pretty hot topic over there on
whether I could be the next Bachelorette
in Australia so that's there's an
interesting thought for me I'm excited
by it I would maybe do it here I don't
know it's up in the air I'm definitely
looking for love what are you looking
for
I honestly someone to share my life with
someone that has already gone through
their own journey of themself and their
career and is ready to just build
something with someone else now and sort
of blend and love and support each other
honestly it's one a share life and
memories and moments yeah if you were to
be the Bachelorette
what kind of Bachelorette would you be
hi this is where I run into trouble with
this thought because honestly what if
what if I'm like I don't like any of
them we're gonna have to recast this
like I can't do that do that though when
you're the Bachelorette you can do
whatever can you do again I don't know
like it's just I think I'm so upfront
and honest about things which is also
great but possibly sometimes my speak
before thinking thing could get me in
trouble and then yeah I don't know I
just makes me nervous clearly because
I'm rambling and I don't know how to
it's the question what is the biggest
difference between the Bachelorette in
Australia and here I think honestly I
don't know that there's that much of a
major difference is very much the same
format if their goal is to find love and
a genuine connection I think the one
over here has a really high success rate
with people that have bent about finding
their way to each other those I thought
we had a lot more drama I don't know
it's very much the same family the same
show and yeah the same message trying to
find love before I let you go
could you ask Hanabi for some advice how
to help a girl out am I supposed to do
the Bachelorette or not I'm stressed
yeah
[Music]